look this nebulous strike panel lines
taking forever yeah it's taking longer
than when corporal Schneider X took his
galaxy cruisers to the glorp system they
captured the spots traders who had
kidnapped pearl onna the star Inquisitor
because she had ruled against them in
the high Galactic Court of Loom and row
5 because she had received a blorph
payoff from the Delta faction who were
trying to use the courts to legitimize
their hostile takeover of the accordion
minds-on Dirksen's moon on tape I think
you mean this line is taking longer than
when corporal snart acts took his galaxy
cruisers to the clammin system to
capture the sworn stray ders who would
kidnapped per loan at the Star
Inquisitor because she had ruled against
them in the high Galactic Court of Luman
defied because she had received a blorph
payoff from the Delta faction who were
trying to use the courts to legitimize
their hostile takeover of the in Cordia
Lions on Dirksen's moon hunting so what
you man the climate system is actually
very close to corporal Stern axis home
planet June which means that using the
Galaxy cruisers ion Tripler engines that
the epic engineer's developed on Judas
moon Charon from the torreón deposits it
would actually take corporal Snorlax 3
milliseconds to sense work there which
is in no way representative of this very
slow line what you meant to say sir is
that the clam on system is actually very
close to corporal Snerd access home
planet Juna which means that using the
ion Tripler engines that the epic
engineers on Judas moon carom developed
from the Latium deposits it would only
take corporal snow decks 3 milliseconds
to synth work which is in no way
representative but that's very so line
I'll kick your ass worse than when Luo
man under 5 venture Brigade flew to
Dirksen to beat the out of Brigham you
mean you keep my ass worse than when you
add or five hunter Brigade flew on tank
to beat the outer brigands we all love
the nebula Strike movies here have a
Snickers I still think you're way out of
line confusing the globe system and the
clam own system but hey at least it's
cool that corporals nerd act slaughtered
those thousands of sports traders
totally agree that syntax is
indiscriminate slaughter was very cool
yeah he really did wipe out that entire
planet and every living soul on it
didn't he he sure did you're the
sci-fi fan when you're hungry eat a
Snickers